when did you dream up this book when did
you know that you were gonna do this
he's about three years ago yeah yeah man
how long did it take to really make this
happen God I mean about two and a half
of those three years me because it's one
thing to have an idea and then we sit
down actually start trying to develop
the plot and the characters and all that
stuff
ideas start taking twists and turns man
so you think of it as being one thing
and it turns out me and some completely
there mmm now today you are number one
on New York bestseller list on New York
Times bestseller list what does that
feel like to be number one with a book
and a project that you love so much it's
a crazy feeling I mean you know to have
a crazy night crazy idea find a great
team to believe in the idea find a great
writer
Wesley King you take the idea and make
it a thousand times better than what it
was now here we are like the design of
the book everybody that kind of worked
on it we really invested our time
invested ourselves in developing in it
so to be number one in New York Times
it's a great feeling I also heard that
you love this book because it's a way to
communicate with your girls who are
getting a little older and they don't
want to always hear from dad yeah just
true with all of our stories coming out
so all the messaging is things that as a
parent we want our kids to learn know
yeah it it's like you have kids all you
know it becomes white noise after a
while they're like all right what do you
guys know you guys don't know what
you're talking about
so finding creative ways to put those
very impactful messages within the story
this way we do it in a creative work so
there's two things you're doing you're
you're producing stuff and winning
awards you're also having children
another one's on the way what are you
are you gonna go at five or you gonna go
for five well that's v's called as the
beast cause it's completely nice call
but I mean we're just really blessed
very fortunate then we have you know
three beautiful healthy you know young
ladies and with another one on the way
so we're just just very very fortunate
but okay what's that dynamic like cuz
you have a volleyball player yeah and
you have a basketball player then you
have one two little determine she's
gonna do what what is that like cuz I
love the picture of you in Italy
carrying her in the baby bjorn she she
has so much energy
it's outrageous
like it's out I mean it's crazy like
she'll do gymnastics like Mommy and Me
class and then swim class and then
she'll come home and run around and then
she'll want to you know shoot hoops with
Gigi and the shoot and then you come
like you know 8 o'clock 9 o'clock
kids ready to go to sleep right no she's
still going still going still going the
kid does not stop like we call it a
little mini tornado Wow
Gigi's a basketball player she is that
she's in it does she have that inner
focus like her daddy yeah she's uh she
just don't go killer out there yeah yeah
at both ends of the floor and she plays
defense as well as offense man she
competes how is she handling because now
there's a lot of YouTube videos out
there like Kobe's daughter destroys
other girls how's that going no she's
not tripping about it I mean you know
it's the you know what I try to teach
the girls and I just heard about all the
girls on the team is it's a process you
just work every day we only started
playing about a year ago ok so he's just
chipping away at it you just get better
and better
y'all practice every night is that every
single night what what is that like
every night practice well I'll make it
fun right so you make it things that
they're learning mm-hmm you make it
enjoyable you don't run them you know
you know all this crazy stuff but you're
just teaching the game in increments
right you got a five-year plan just
teach the game patiently and see where
they are 5 years from now you also have
had a chance to by working with the
girls team you were at the Women's Final
Four and you really have recognized
women's basketball how important is that
to let people know that it's still
really good basketball well it's great
basketball you know quite frankly the
people that don't understand that yet
mm-hmm I just India to be honest with
you I mean it's a beautiful game and
what I want to do is get out and and
publicize the game to young women even
more so so we can get more women
competing more women participating in
this beautiful game and you know see
where the game is 20 years ago I heard
you don't have basketball memorabilia in
your in your office but you do have an
Oscar what do you guys do you keep the
Oscar Oh office it I keep it at home I
keep I keep it at home and you know I
use it as motivation
when you have something like for example
during the writing of wizard our and
some of the other stories it's like you
have days where like man I don't know if
we can we figure this out I don't know
right and you look there and you see the
Oscar and you're like I don't know if
we're gonna figure out but we're gonna
keep on moving you know so it's kind of
a form of motivation what's better Oscar
or an NBA championship ring an Oscar man
yeah not supposed to win an Oscar you
know like as a kid you grew up you like
you know I'm a plain NBA I'm gonna win
championships okay all right that's
that's somewhat in the realm of
possibility when you're with your
friends yeah I was 10 years old and
that's what my friends say I'm gonna win
an Oscar by you know what I mean even to
myself it's just not it's not reality
nobody realities so that has to be
number one last thing give did some work
with Taylor Swift didn't you yeah you
did some stuff with teller I went out I
went out on the stage and introduced a
nice banner for at Staples Center yeah
and yeah my kids thought it was the
dorkiest move ever did they well yeah
because she you know sure she had
special guests right and so now Dahlia
is asking as I will who's your special
guest it's just like it's your father
what why why is he the special guest we
got gypped that's the kind of event
that's what I did at home and that's how
the girls fell that's how they vote
you